hello everybody and welcome to a
practical Python with flask tutorial
series in this video and in this series
what we're going to be talking about is
building this website you see here
basically from scratch to where it is
now so python programming dotnet is my
website that's where we host a bunch of
Python programming tutorials basically
all the tutorials you see on my channel
are also on this website also in written
form so we're going to be using flask
which is a Python web framework and I
actually already have a basic series on
flask which is right here so you can go
through those if you want to get the
basics but this series is going to be
more practical and pragmatic approach
and we're actually going to build a
website so depending on your learning
style one of these two series will
probably be more interesting to you so
what we're going to be using is actually
this websites fairly basic and fairly
easy to build
so what shouldn't be too difficult
actually if this is your first entrance
into even web development in general
although I would suggest you know at
least the basics of HTML just so you can
kind of follow what's happening most web
developers that I know don't tend to
write the majority of their own HTML and
CSS and even like JavaScript they copy
and paste from examples and they edit
and kind of manipulate to their liking
so in staying with the reality of things
that is actually what we'll be doing
here the flask will be all handwritten
there shouldn't be at least that I can
think of any copy and paste there but a
lot of bootstrap and stuff like that
I'll show you exactly the process I go
through so bootstrap has a website and
you go there and you can kind of look at
their examples of things that you can do
with bootstrap and then you just
basically copy and paste and kind of
edit and change so it's actually a lot
easier than it might seem so with that
let's go ahead and get started so we're
just going to jump in and just just go
so there won't be really too much other
explanation I'll try to explain things
as I go as far as the first time around
what's happening but other than that
it's going to be a pretty practical
approach the first thing we need
obviously is some sort of server you
and host it locally if you want the only
thing I'll say before we go this route
is one I'm going to put it on a live
server so it will be accessible via the
Internet do not have the same live
server production server as your
development servers so basically do not
develop on your live website it's a bad
idea for a couple of reasons or at least
a couple major reasons first is it's bad
for your users right they're gonna have
a lot of downtime and disruption and
bugs and all this kind of stuff but even
more importantly it's a security risk
you if you're developing you're going to
introduce bugs and even if they're for a
short live time or whatever someone can
get in build up a backdoor or whatever
and or even just get in and don't even
need a backdoor maybe one of your
security measures is bugged out because
of some update you've made something
like that just a bad idea do not develop
on a live server that's all I'm going to
say on the matter we are going to be
developing on a server that's accessible
by the internet for a couple of reasons
we want to have a server that as as I
code I can at least tell you about
things that happen so when you take
python from the local little sandbox
mode on your computer and you put it on
a web server all of a sudden the poop
hits the fan and things just don't work
the same as you expect them to all of a
sudden for example pythons garbage
collection I don't know they just stop
collecting garbage so there's a lot of
like little things that come when you
push to production so I'd like to kind
of talk about them in line as we code so
with that let's get started because I'm
doing a tutorial series because I want
it to be a live server I'm going to be
using digitalocean and the main reason
why we'll use them is because they have
a $5 a month option
my preferred house is actually Linode
com but they're cheapest option is ten
dollars a month so I'm going to
digitalocean
I have links to both in the description
they are referral links and it gets me
discounts on my hosting so if you use
them thank you anyway so I'll be using
digitalocean as far as the rest of the
tutorial goes you actually it does not
matter which host you use and you can
even host locally if you want it's
totally
fine but we will be using my sequel so
if you're hosting locally especially on
Windows you are going to have a headache
but anyway uh-huh so I'm going to choose
this $5 a month thing I would type in
I've already created the server but the
name out
ours is going to be as flat suits so
you'll choose this size flash tuts you
can always resize later don't worry
about it or if you can pick your region
this is kind of it doesn't really matter
much nowadays but if you're expecting
your website to be mostly used let's say
in London you would pick a london-based
server mostly in the United States pick
one of the United States
you've got west coast East Coast all
around the world you know you might want
to pick one of these other websites or
uh server locations settings here I
would uh this one's the only major one
you will pay extra for enabling backups
but you will not regret it everybody
thinks they won't need backups or
everybody thinks that they're going to
make their own backups
some people do congratulations if that's
you I used to think I would I did it
every now and then but I not enough I've
never regretted paying for backups
distributions we're going to be doing
this series you can you can use 1404
obutu if you want but we're going to do
it with 14.10 so it's the newest version
if there's a newer version as you're
watching feel free to use it should be
totally fine and then scrolling down you
can add SSH keys if you're familiar with
doing that we're not going to cover that
here and when you're all done you'll
click create a droplet once you create
the droplet it usually takes about a
minute but once you've done it you
should it'll be done and you'll come
after basically on digitalocean even get
here I didn't really say much but you
create an account obviously log in and
click create a droplet and then once
you've done that you click on droplets
and you'd come here I just don't really
want to show all my other droplets and
their IPS so I just want to show this
one so once you come in here you've got
flash toots uh and this is our droplet
it's powered on but you don't know the
are the password if you use digitalocean
if you use Linode you actually you'll go
into like settings and you'll set the
password yourself and that's it if you
use digitalocean they will send you an
email I've got it up on my phone
you'll need to the first time you log in
you'll change the password so being that
this is a pragmatic practical series I'm
just going to show literally everything
I do so now I need to go change my
password there's a couple of methods for
logging in for now
I'm just going to use the console I
promise we will not be using this
console in the rest of the series I'm
just going to use it because it's here
and we're going to use it so anyway I'll
click on console access it'll connect if
it is just a black screen hit like the
Enter key or something and you'll see
here it says something and it's
connected but I don't see a login I hit
enter there's my login the initial user
name is root and so I'm going to use
root for the login and then the password
they sent to you it's probably jumbled
up list of letters I'm going to enter
mine okay so I logged in and now it says
basically since this is the first time
we've logged in I have to change my
password again so here I go to change it
well first you have to enter the current
one so enter that same password they
sent you again okay now you enter a new
password this will be the password you
better remember okay and just for the
record obviously again if this is a live
server for your password you want to
obviously pick something that's a decent
password that someone isn't going to be
able to guess or it can't be a
dictionary word although I'm pretty sure
Linux will actually decline you if you
attempt to enter a dictionary word it'll
be like no that's not good enough
pick something better so anyway so we're
in and now I want to talk about we're
not going to use this console I think
it's just kind of silly to use it but so
we're going to leave and that's
basically it the only other thing just
remember what your password is or I mean
not your password trip' address and your
password remember that it's a good idea
and because you're going to use this IP
address now how are we going to actually
connect to our website there's tons of
options out there my choices may not be
your choices and that's totally fine it
really doesn't matter in the end you
just need to get files to and from and
be able to issue commands I tend to like
SCP and I use
SCP I'm gonna bring it down here in just
a second let me get this listen this
over here good enough okay so this is
Wynne SCP and I've connected as my root
user so it stuffs me in this root but
this is we can go back whoops we can go
back here and this is this is are all
like the [ __ ] the directories and files
of our server right now there's not too
much here for us I can't really show you
too much because this is just a clean
server but basically all the files that
are required so this is winscp and win
for windows SCP for secure copy and
paste so it's a lot like an FTP client
like filezilla if you're familiar you
can also use FileZilla for exactly the
same reasons why I'm using SCP I like
SCP it's a little faster generally but
this will actually fall back on SFTP
which is secure File Transfer Protocol
which is what FileZilla is although
FileZilla FTP or SFTP it isn't it you
kind of choose and so anyway this is
what how I will transfer files tuned
from I'll talk a little bit more about
that once we actually have some files on
talk about the editors and stuff like
that and how to change them so that's
winscp if you're not on Windows use
another SCP client or use you know you
can use FileZilla if you're on Windows I
know Mac OS supports FileZilla not
really sure what program I would use if
I was on Linux but I guarantee you
there's some some program or you can
also SCP via the command line so lots of
options there I don't I'm not going to
go through everyone's options but at
least I'll show you on Windows how it
was done finally the other one that is
pretty much a must need it must need it
must have is some sort of SSH which is a
secure shell and SSH is so we can
connect to our server and it's the same
thing that we see here with this console
writes the command line of your server
and so this is where you issue all kinds
of basically commands to your server and
we're going to use it a lot of times at
least for setting up installing packages
getting on
starting in restarting stopping services
and stuff from running this is where
you'll do it so you'll want to have some
sort of shell I use putty and that works
on Windows pretty sure that works on a
Mac OS although I think you can actually
SSH you can SSH bolt on Mac and on Linux
without a program basically you need it
for Windows so anyway again this is how
I do it on Windows if you have a
different operating system you just
basically need to figure out how to do
SCP or some sort of file transferring
thing because it makes development a lot
easier and then also some form of SSH
now anyway I'm going to log in make sure
that worked good once you're logged in
you need to do a couple of things a
first thing I'm going to go ahead and do
is change some settings here we're going
to come down to appearance change my
font size for you fellows it's a little
easier to see and then also colors
default foreground you don't really have
to do this I'm just doing it to make it
easier for you guys to see apply good
fullscreen this bad boy and now
basically the first thing you should
always do when you first get a server is
the following sudo apt-get update and
this basically updates apt-get because
you'll find that sometimes you'll try to
install things and we'll be like oh that
doesn't exist it exists just apt-get is
not updated and then sudo apt-get
upgrade and then it asks you hey do you
want to do this we'll just hit yes if
you're not familiar with the terminal
basically I do have some tutorials on
the terminal as well just like a basics
on flask I got basics on the terminal
although just like you'll be able to
learn flash through this series you'll
probably learn quite a bit about the
terminal just following along I'll try
to explain as I go and just like with
all of my videos and basically anything
with flask and all that if we do
anything in these videos that you don't
understand or you're not really sure
what it did or whatever are you having a
problem leave a comment below and I will
help you out we'll figure out what's
going on so don't really worry about
that don't feel stupid or anything like
that it's kind of confusing and daunting
the first few times that you deal with
these command lines anyway of upgrade is
taking a while so I'm going to go ahead
and cut off the video here that's kind
of where I wanted to stop anyway so it
doesn't matter this shouldn't take you
know about a few minutes usually but
anyway unless it's been a long time so
that's it if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until the next video